good
morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast today is Thursday but it
sure feels like a Friday because it's
our last show of the week I'm heading to
Phoenix tomorrow Friday night show sell
some tickets left Saturday night is sold
out I'm heading to Hamilton New York
tomorrow come join me on my session
Friday on my panel on Saturday where I'm
just gonna be imparting business wisdom
is it like panel with other people one
on Friday it's a solo mission it's not
like a moderator situation that's so
hard like talking about how to building
your brand that's so hard I used to do
this stuff kind of all the time I don't
remember where but it just sounds
familiar
and then Saturday is a panel with fellow
female alums successful in their feet
who anyone we know um no not in like no
because they're not in our industry like
they are close to the coal mining
industry you know so they like they work
in textiles but we don't know that no
because they're not like public figures
like your girl well today it's just a
serene e and gloomy ass Thursday now so
the only thing to really brighten the
spirit of the morning toast was th EO
and he's finally relaxing so I don't
want to say his name because when he
hears anything it's like time to EA T or
G oo u T so he's just chilling with his
mango duck I love hones chew toy and
he's being a precious gem I carried him
here in his carrier that I got him for
Hanukkah and he was not appreciative
like first time I put him in the carrier
and it's like uh sad it's not sad when
it's a Louie Vuitton carrier he's a
spoiled brat that's very true
like he's such a brat well other than
delivering premium ass content Jackie
and I are also here to deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast like I don't know
if you've ever heard of it you know it's
possible it's possible are we gonna jump
right into it so no see I was just
setting the groundwork for every one of
what we're doing you know what we're
doing on the show just in case you have
some new Biore
yeah that would be nice if we had some
new viewers you know like is this your
first time watching the morning toast
how you do it woo we enabled super chat
on our YouTube we don't know what that
means but play around have fun super
chat um I got new boots they're so nice
thank you they're House of Harlow
they're so my friend Nicole Richie made
them ooh they're so Coachella yes so
they're really are my Coachella list of
things to pack Jack and I are pretty
much officially gonna Coachella now we
try to avoid it as much as possible but
you know I'm looking forward to a few
things
I feel like we went the first time we
learned exactly what not to do which is
go to the festival no it's like here's
what not to do don't show up unless you
have a parking pass right and that's
what I that was one of the most valuable
thing that I learned also don't show up
until the Sun Goes Down right and spend
the day getting ready and maybe have it
go into some cool parties but other than
that like nothing crazy
mm-hmm another lesson I learned is
deodorant in between your thighs makes
for an excellent chub rub resister I
didn't know that you didn't know I'm
gonna have something now you're so chin
and you're going to Coachella I say that
Sperry you want to say like everyone
who's calling me small it's nice and
stuff but like I'm just a lot less fat
and I'm still like I consider it a
chubby person and chubby people get chub
rub and that's something I'll just have
to deal with probably for the rest of my
life and that is your cross to bear so
annoying it's like when I wear a pair of
Spanx underneath an outfit or like biker
shorts it solves the chub-rub problem
immediately but so many Coachella
outfits are like not Spanx friendly it's
like too short or high slit like it's
too tight it's too long of a day no that
doesn't even bother me I can handle the
Spanx treachery but it's like Coachella
outfits don't allow for Spanx or even
biker shorts damn no I can that's my
cross to bear I couldn't do things I
would die oh my god I could I die
without Spanx no but they're so tight
like you feel queasy I don't know
whatever we'll figure out all the
logistics the word we're getting excited
actually we want to be successful for
the industry that we're in that requires
going to Coachella no it's like we
consider ourselves to be like at the
epicenter of all things cool fun and
trendy yet we don't want to go to
Coachella that's just like not an option
do you know what I mean I understand I
do and that's why we're going and that's
our cross to bear right how many times
we should say that today you think I
don't know it's one of those cross to
bear episodes no no I know it
that's our cross to bear and then we're
also gonna be echoed at stagecoach it's
just you know what I realized it's
festival season
it truly is are you gonna win sock no
that's actually I kind of want to go to
Lollapalooza like I never thought those
words would come out of my mouth in my
life no but it's like in a major city so
there's hotels and Kacey Musgraves is
headlining and Ariana Grande yeah sounds
teeny to me yeah now that we're seeing
ariana grande Coachella I really feel
like I don't have to see sweetener tour
and like a part of me like really just
like has anxiety and like doesn't want
to go I know I don't I went to her show
um with little mix with little mix
little make
was great and it's like there's nothing
that you'd like me to see that you have
to go for and it's only she's the type
of person who like holds back with
Taylor Schiff it's like if you want to
see Taylor Swift you have to go to her
concert cuz she's nowhere else right I
am a grande is everywhere in addition to
being on tour right but we'll see her at
Coachella now hey hey how was your first
day of spring
it definitely sprung on me you know that
it was spring and that was really that
was my cross to bear right that's gonna
become like one of our new things I kind
of loved it
um no it was great I mean I was busy in
meetings with you all day you know just
like me actually yesterday I got into
bed and I was like this has been the
most productive day of my life like so
many things happen for me on a personal
but also mostly like a professional
level like just deals coming through I
mean it's like the old saying goes when
it rains it pours
totally and today it's [ __ ] pouring
for a million different reasons but I
just felt like yesterday like was my day
do you know what I mean and I have been
on the road so much and this week was
supposed to be my week of like catching
up on sleep time with Theo time with Ben
like making memory is also being
productive and I really feel like I've
caught up on so much sleep I'm so well
rested yesterday I got into bed and I
was like oh my god
I was not tired today wow I don't think
I've ever had that feeling like since
the second grade that's an exciting
feeling so I'm just feeling like all
caught up like on my emails on my sleep
on my business affairs and I'm just I'm
catching up on television I'm all caught
up on my Housewives I'm watching shrill
like I'm just feeling like so
accomplished half of it and like that is
not a feeling I'm used to feeling I
understand so I'm happy for you
thank you I'm happy for you know that I
am even if I can't understand I'll tell
you the pain give me the truth me and my
heart will make it through
I'm happy for you you never know who's
listening big music exec you never know
who's listening honestly I don't feel as
rested because they drink kind of week
night last night because it was the
first day of spring and as predicted
Rebecca wanted to get drinks that was
the funniest thing ever she literally
text me right up to the show she was
like you know it's the first day to
drink a first day of spring maybe we
should celebrate with some crisps on
there and I was like you have to watch
the toast
well just describing said Sara's crisp
makes me want to have a glass and I even
like wine right so yeah then she
listened to the toast and we were
laughing but then apparently Monson so
many people message me I'm sorry that
was something so many people attended I
heard apparently a Montezuma apparently
on something because so many people like
got text messages from people being like
it's the first day of spring league
let's celebrate with drinks like I'm
telling you there's something about
spring and drinks and I think we should
do a study on it because all of a sudden
I had three drinks one night well you
wouldn't hear something so funny I'm
definitely in that mood because I'm
going out tonight and I'm like you know
what let's get drinks I'm going I'm one
of a Broadway play with tbg oh I'm going
to dinner me but what sync up totally
and I was like tbg originally was like
let's go me you and Margo and Margo's
away so I'm like Ben's gonna come
so what open I'm like man by the way
Persinger Broadway I was ready for him
to be like ah so he's like what are we
seeing and I'm like Oklahoma like I
don't even know what that is and he's
like oh Oklahoma he knows that yeah I'm
like what I don't even know what that is
um it's a big it's a big show I have no
idea what it's about it's so funny like
when we started this show you were like
Claudia please make sure that you don't
get distracted by feel no but he wasn't
distracted I was my eyes were distracted
but I I think about the podcast lesson
but like no guys look I've been talking
just me for nine minutes because you've
been watching to4 nightmare that's I
mean but you had to be with him all the
time and like I said how you take it
whatever you want I always tell you that
and you just don't want to bear that
cross me forget the cross has been born
right Baird let's board the Cross has
been looking they're a married I don't
[ __ ] know I don't know my parent okay
what's that from
no it's very it's Bert I don't know okay
and totally are you ready for the past
pack wait wait I don't know I don't know
like I don't feel I sent you an
Instagram story last night of a real
estate listening that somebody DM to me
that looked a lot like Erika Jaynes
house but it's okay I don't think that
it was because of the backyard didn't
look like where she kept her birthday
party yes and two it would have said
there's a chapel in the description
truly but then it's just like maybe
she's making so much money off her shoe
dazzle Club that like she just needs a
bigger estate like a 20 million dollar I
think she would sooner renovate the
existing see I mean that would be wise
yeah did you get the shoe dazzle shoes I
got two pairs yes I love my I got an
Erika Jayne and then an Erika Girardi
pair like one for the bedroom one for
the boardroom that's two amazing ones
and I'm so excited to wear them
I love she does what I'm actually a VIP
member yeah don't talk to me like you
gotta get to the back it's like I'm VIP
um VIPs like me save 30% off most retail
prices all day every day Plus get free
shipping and returns you get this really
fun style quiz to personalize your
shopping experience it's a flexible
membership so each month you can shop or
skip and again VIPs get 30% off every
single day
so check out Erika Girardi shoot outs of
collection today make sure to sign up as
a VIP when you do because right now
you'll get your first pair of shoes for
75% off as low as $10 this is an
exclusive deal for podcast listeners so
make sure you go to ShoeDazzle comm /
toast to get it
that's shoot dazzled comm / toast to
step up your look today for as low as
$10 ShoeDazzle comm / toast
honestly the Erika Girardi pair that I
got it wish I got them a few days before
I actually would have worn them to my
wedding because they were beautiful
white satin pearly shoes they match my
barrette today which people are loving
in the comments I just ordered a
barrette is this barrette or beret or
braised I have a beret is a hat a
Beretta it's a clip and first of all
like Brett's are really in right now and
I really was enjoying wearing one today
because I feel like my hair always looks
so weird from this side on the show cuz
this actually isn't my good side I gave
you the good side please did you go
check it out ok should we switch one day
that would be so trippy let's do it
right now right now actually th EO
finally lay down and I just want you to
tell he's finally being in normal person
no I ordered I finally got it
it's from Urban Outfitters I finally got
some [ __ ] from something Navy it's like
every time I go it's all sold out but I
happened to be online at noon like
yesterday and I got a couple things
including some barrettes cute
Rex art and I think they were for the
children's collection but that works
that does work yeah it's just so easy
and you know when Maya was wearing her
hair like in barrettes
when they went to Sylvain Sol airing it
just looked really cute so that's where
I'm at and Doreen of course three
chemically the queen of barrettes I
appreciate her expressing herself
through fashion hair makeup but I do
think like the hair needs to be just
taken to a new level and I'm
disappointed because I know she hires
Kardashian level glam to do her hair
like she's a senior that she's chasing
March another her hair she always has
makeup like from Kardashian like
throwaways and I just think they could
be doing a better job of the hair oh I
think her hair is always great and
interesting except for that like curly
LaDonna holy sue ramen noodle just
remember like without that if you took
that out of the equation then it's just
like I think would be every the gold
wasn't even the ones that I don't love
like or the bobbies I didn't love it but
like it was interesting to look at I
know but I appreciate people who try I
appreciate people who try and she looked
incredible at Camille's birthday and her
Alessandra rich dress my boots are Alice
and her rich so I just feel rich those
are really cute boots aren't they
they're my favorite boots ever I got
them for my birthday I wore them to the
CMA Awards in Kacey Musgraves love them
yes she did
I hope she got herself a pair anyways
isn't about Alessandra Ridge but it is
about the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
okay first story we found under the car
yesterday on the way home from the Tosa
for some reason really like struck me
what Emma Roberts ends her engagement
with Evan Peters and moves on with
Garrett Hedlund if you don't know who
Garrett Hedlund is he is from Country
Strong and he is from Georgia rule yeah
I know Garrett Hedlund he is you have
terrible taste in movies right and so
not only does he have amazing taste in
movies but like he has a great agent who
has wonderful taste in scripts because
those were like two unknown scripts
right and like the movies like were
sidetracked by the fact like Lindsay
Lohan was the star and when if coucher
was to start but nobody realizes like
the real like both of those both of
those films had like moral dilemmas and
like it really was like an internal I
don't know debate within me to just like
what is this movie trying to teach me
what did they say in books when you were
a kid every book had the moral of the
story you don't judge a book by its
cover right Garrett Hedlund is just I
mean I think that this Evan Peters Emma
Roberts relationship has been fraught
with peril yeah and I just I didn't
think they were ever really in it for
the long haul
I didn't even realize that we're back
together I just don't think like Emma
Roberts literally like the teenage
American dream like
America's Sweetheart like is with Evan
Peters I got him sleep over you know is
that what he's from in my he's also from
American Horror Story which I believe
they met through like the Ryan Murphy
circle but in my eyes he'll always be
the skater boy from sleepover who liked
oh my god like to Sarah what was her
name aquamarine the girl who played
aquamarine Sara Paxton Sara Paxton yes
not Yancey no not you answer yes he was
with the DJ guy who loved brownies you
know how in Mean Girls there's that line
like I understand what you mean it's my
my nieces I mean my nephew is named and
we get so mad when everyone calls him
Anthony almost as much as as mad as I
get when I think about the fact that my
aunt my sister named Jim Anthony yeah
Yancy and AM Ferdie need to get together
they do Wow
anyways I think Emma Roberts is like the
most eligible Bachelorette in Holley
right that's what I'm saying I think she
is everything the stuff she has a great
career but also like a nice it seems
like she's work life balance she has a
book club which just seems like someone
who's knowledgeable so she has much you
have a lot of knowledge I saw her at
Paris's birthday and like I really
wanted to go over and say hi just be
like I love you but like she's a follow
me on Instagram and she like has no idea
who I am or like what is Trevor girls
talking to her right but I just like she
was so such like a normal party girl
like she was at a party she was like
hanging out with her friends like you
see celebrities are different and like a
lot of them are but like she just came
with a bunch of girlfriends I was having
such a good time dancing and look left
right and like let me not forget the
unfabulous of it all cuz it's like
sometimes she seems so glam and like you
know too highbrow
yeah but then it's like she was
unfabulous know and then you think it's
like she's on she's like this highbrow
star but she's always better unfabulous
that's her cross to bear
I think highbrow was the best way to
describe her yeah I mean no I want to
say truly like because she's the nephew
oh my god she's the niece of Julia
Roberts she too has an aunt City Ches
but what I was going to say is like she
is really the niece of America's
Sweetheart making her like America's
Sweetheart and training right or it's
like America's niece America's niece
heart of America's sweet niece yes I
mean America's sweet nephew
Laing do not write him up he's finally
behaving I won't but they have the
cameras on him and it's it's pretty
unfabulous was such a good show and I
love the theme song I like how at the
end all the letters came together and
like she was the L you know like it's
better been fabulous but anyway so I'm
happy to see her with Garrett Hedlund
I'm sorry for her broken engagement but
personally Evan Peters never did it for
me and like I don't know that he was
worthy I mean I'm really happy that
Garrard had LUN moved on after you know
the love of his life Kelly canter
committed suicide and I just think like
everyone moves on in their own way and
their own time and this is the perfect
time for Garrett yeah and this is the
perfect girl forget right and I've told
Lindsay Lohan to give him a [ __ ] in
that rowboat like he deserved more that
movie is so good actually need to be
watched Georgia but you're also like
conflating like they're one movie yes no
I'm totally clear he's the same person
he though I'm trying my Garrett
headlands love life like first he
basically got assaulted by Lindsay Lohan
in that rowboat then he falls in love
with Kelly canter goes on tour with her
and she commits suicide like he's had
such a tough but and then he actually
winds up with Leighton Meester and
there's like tried to pass it off like
they were meant for each other but like
totally I wasn't that's a flaw in the
movie right I could actually I couldn't
have except for I guess what they're
trying to say he's like on the tour and
throughout the movie like Leighton
Meester she started as like the shallow
girl but like through Kelly and these
experiences she like became a little bit
deeper and then when the suicide
happened she sort of it changed her into
a woman that Garrett could I disagree
ready I think that Garrett was so caught
up and like this whirlwind fake romance
with like Kelly and he kind of felt
protective over her and he was so like
sidetracked by that he didn't even
really get to fully fall for Leighton
Meester because he thought she was
shallow but she really wasn't like she
was always doing those flashcards in the
trailer like she was really like a smart
girl but it's like kind of I got people
view us like they think we're stupid cuz
we say like a hundred times like we're
actually quite profound
if you just get to know us but if you
just like judge a book by it's cover
like she's just a summer girl who wears
her flip-flops right she and like she
lives you let your hair down oh the
party never stops obviously isn't like
you think you hear her songs like that's
such a stupid son like I'm just to
summer but listen to the words like I
wear my flip-flops but when I let my
hair down the party never [ __ ] stops
and who needs a boyfriend I've got my
girlfriend's the feminist of our
generation just a thought just a thought
agreed anyways I look forward to
following
what that's Leighton Meester's cross to
bear no her Aziza bear is that like
she's Blair Waldorf and she'll never be
anything else you married Seth Cohen and
they truly don't care like they could be
so much more than they are I know it's
like if anyone was gonna have really the
The Suite Life of kind of Montana of our
generate their world often Seth Cohen
neat and if anyone was gonna marry her
and it wasn't Rachel Bilson I'm so like
it wasn't summer Roberts I'm so glad
that it was Blair Waldorf right and if
you think about it like Blair Waldorf
like totally went to OC like for the
summers and like fell in love with Seth
Cohen like didn't tell anyone about like
her nerdy like Jewish boyfriend from the
West Coast you know no or like Seth
Cohen
totally like transfer to NYU because
RISD just wasn't cutting it for him and
then he met Blair and at first they're
like two neighbors in the hallway and
they're so different you know cuz she's
so Graham and like he's so right look
she's like Elle Woods
yeah and he's so like Emmett emo but
then I guess he's kind of like 'no Dan
Humphrey except that he he's normal yeah
we totally got sidetracked but basically
Garrett Hedlund I've been exploiting
everyone's secrets for a loser a website
and Emma Roberts are together I wonder
how they met because he like doesn't
really work that much anymore oh and you
know he actually used to be with Kirsten
Dunst he's got such an interesting
career like he's not famous like he can
he lives a normal life but he liked but
he's a respected actor right by us what
is he working on now I have no idea I
have no idea I mean we're literally
writing fanfiction right now no I know
and like that's so crazy that she ended
her engagement and has already moved on
and I wonder when they actually ended
there but in other ways it's like a
Britney Aldean situation yeah but this
but there's no children involved so I
actually can't forget okay my point yet
that I was trying to make yesterday is
like we stand these couples like the her
G of X and the Aldean's but lest we not
forget how it all started that's one
example for you I wanna know if you
forgotten Eileen Davidson what did what
was her story her and her husband were
both married when they got together
don't forget okay
you haven't obviously no I haven't well
I did until I was thinking today while I
was doing my makeup but they this little
table that was supposed to be like
decorative for us in the middle has now
become like actual storage I have Theo's
garbage I might have some old cups a lip
liner a lipstick a lip gloss a faux I
just have a pony in mine and my coffee
clean my [ __ ] up sorry I'm just like you
know being so messy today oh [ __ ] he's
okay it's okay he's good are you ready
for our next story I don't know I'm just
like I'm really not over this whole Evan
Peters thing and it's like how did have
been Peters go from the guy and sleep
over like the skater he was a skater boy
he said see you later boy
and now he's just like a Ryan Murphy
number one not even three or five right
it makes you think it does in other
words work rates displacement and
anything could happen anything could
happen
we're very animated today are we
anything could you stop [ __ ] Lovett
are me and when they perform that twice
X Factor my life was made it was
life-changing
true okay next story she's here Jessica
Simpson and husband Eric Johnson welcome
daughter birdie may she's here Jessica
Simpson and husband Eric Johnson
multiple their third child together
daughter Bertie Mae Johnson on Tuesday
March 19th her rep confirms two people
exclusively baby birdy weighed 10 pounds
13 ounces that is a big bet I mean I'm
not shocked because if you saw her most
recent Instagram of her in a bikini when
she was pregnant her actual belly was
huge I'm having twins I'm not trying to
body shaming a newborn no no I'm just
saying you weigh 10 pounds that makes
sense because the belly was bit right
and like by you know larger standards
that's a that's a bigger baby than by
logic if a big you okay liam hemsworth
s-- wife there is a bikini picture of
them when she's pregnant I think with
twins and like she's a tiniest most
petite small woman and her belly is
enormous because she was having twins
mm-hmm well we are so happy and proud to
announce the birth of our perfect
daughter Bernie made onsens Simpson
wrote on Instagram Wednesday sharing a
black-and-white photo of her older
daughter meeting the new addition so Tia
Simpson and the former NFL player also
shares son ace Newt five and daughter
Maxwell maxi drew six and a half Cubans
there's such a cute family you know also
when I think about the trajectory of
Jessica Simpson's career I'm quite
baffled she is someone who figured it
out she figured it out it's like I
didn't even realize at the time I mean I
loved her I'm loving angels instead like
there was
I really was like her number-one fan and
she was my birthday buddy cuz we both
were July 10th so I was really like
invested in her career and then it's
like she just randomly decided after her
Nick Lachey broke up like to not sing
anymore and just made this Kmart line
that like I literally blew up and like
all her monies came our money now and
that's the best kind and she flies
private like from the came our money I
think not from like her husband who's an
ex NFL player but it's both you know
it's kind of like Kristin Cavallari and
Jay Cutler well yeah he's so respected
as a football player and then like she's
really out here doing it no I don't know
if Jessica Simpson husband is so
respected as a football player oh yeah
big deal I think they know and maybe and
he definitely is now but like I couldn't
see Jessica Simpson wasn't she dating
Tony Romo you don't go from like Tony
Romo to the benchwarmer I mean Tony Romo
is the most prestigious hot [ __ ] ever
and honestly I have to find this picture
I'll never forget like I used to be
obsessed of Jessica Simpson and there
was this picture she threw him a
birthday party or he threw her birthday
party
it was actually she threw him my
birthday party and they'd like a Dallas
Cowboys cake and it was blue and they
liked it was one of those birthday
parties I was like sponsored and like
all the paparazzi were there and they
like threw the frosting at each other
there's like such a cute picture of them
I covered in blue frosting hold on I
gotta find it like this it was like on
my mood board as a ten year old I was
obsessed with Jessica Simpson do you
want that for your birthday party yes
Tony Romo what are cool Jessica Simpson
blue cake frosting birthday all right
give me a sec I'll get something okay
it's like not exactly what I remembered
but it may say I was right like they
just had this photo shoot of them a bird
in frosting that's cute
yeah and I just remember being really
inspired by it and like wanting that for
myself when I grew up
you know should remake well Ben's Burt
you should throw been a birthday well
I'm actually knew it you know what they
say you want something make it happen
say it on the toast
I'm trying for a been a birthday party
and like honestly I was saying I'm like
you know what Ben deserves the world
like he's such a great husband he's been
putting up with me like being gone for
so long I'm like I want to throw him a
bang and aspart they party but it's like
I'm out here and I'm like you know I'm
an allocate budget for this I'm out of
here with my big budget and it's very
small right because I found like one
place that was on my budget and I'm like
it was ready to sign the paperwork I
make wait by the way like this room
because I want to do like a private room
and a restaurant or a bar I'm like this
is for the night right two and a half
hours I'm like [ __ ] Andrea whatever
your name was
she would have ours who is it to to have
our party I'm like I want I need the
whole night and I wanted to be open bar
like I'm really trying
money at this and like no one will let
me more what if you did two and a half
hours like ORS Devore's and cocktail I
don't even want or support and once we
away [ __ ] starts it like 10:30 and then
at 12:00 we go to the club
no cuz like honestly I flip what you old
to be going to clubs and like mean I've
been trying to tell you this herself
I won't no it's not even that it's like
okay if I want to go to club I can
choose ten people to go to the club with
me but like Ben has so many friends like
for my birthday I have 23 friends easy
but for betting is so many friends like
they just want to like celebrate party
or might not be rushed to go somewhere
and like it's being proven to be so
difficult like I might have to hit up
some free venues at the Seaport honestly
it's um it's really hard also because
his birthday last year was iconic and
perfect and so him and the that's his
idea of a perfect birthday so if it's
not that it could only be worse you know
right and last year I had the best of
both worlds I got the venue for free
then I made a cash bar so ever just like
bought thrown drinks and I paid all the
money for my budget on the band which
was this 90s cover band saved by the 90s
they were amazing this year I don't have
the venue anymore I just feel like now
it's like we're established a ben is a
little bit older you know we're very
successful I think it's time for an open
bar knockout and Gail did knock on wood
but don't you think it's time for an
open bar like should I be having a cash
bar at Ben's birthday I don't know it
depends on the situation and other
amenities that you're offering if
there's nothing else but like last year
you gave everyone the ride of their
lives what it's a Biden what's there so
you by the time saved by the 90s like
that was the gift and so yes I'll pay
for my drinks you know right but now
it's like I just want to have a DJ a
dance fun lit party with just an open
bar in a cool private room with some
balloons and it's like that's hard to do
I guess ya know it's really hard in in
the city no one look I was allocating
budget and I was like I can go anywhere
with my budget no okay we have to get
creative and I just don't maybe there's
something at the Seaport there's a lot
of cool spaces I just thought maybe if I
set it out loud now a cool venue would
email me or something Claudia that girl
with no job calm that's Claudia a girl
with no job dot-com and we're happy to
you know thirst out in any way we need
to anyways the cantos is like really
soon I know when our ducks in a row
totally and I need to start like
training for it because like it's a lot
of physical a stamina yeah you know it's
physically laborious and you know what
that's our cross to bear
actually across the bear because we did
this to ourselves yes but it's worth
every sore muscle well I'm really happy
for Jessica Simpson I feel like she is a
fertile Myrtle just like she's our
priorities you know that's true but she
just has her priorities in line just
like dang and our babies I think just
seems happy and like that's where she
wants to be in life yes wonderful
and reminds me of a new partner that
we're working with and I'm so excited to
share with the toasters from a personal
level but also because you know the
toaster communities are very vocal a lot
of new moms a lot of retiring moms they
wanted to tell you guys about modern
fertility modern fertility is the first
comprehensive fertility hormone test for
women that you can take at home we're
waiting longer to have kids we've got
stuff to do we've got morning shows to
host but it's posing a problem one in
six couples has trouble conceiving we
all have the tools to prevent pregnancy
but we need more information to help us
plan for it even if kids are in the far
far future weren't near distant future
modern fertility gives you customized
reports to help you understand your
fertility through hormones you'll have a
personal fertility team to help you
understand your results and make a game
plan you get access to a team of
fertility nurses a weekly webinar and
their online community of women just
like you so everyone has their reasons -
turning from to turning to modern
fertility whether it's to find out
information to use now or information
that will help you plan for the future
but for me and for I'm you know I assume
for you it's the peace of mind that
makes it so are it whether you want kids
now or in the future you can use modern
fertility results and resources to map
things out on your own terms
we don't quote wait and see for anything
else in our lives and fertility doesn't
have to be any different take the
fertility quiz and get $20 off your
first kid at modern fertility calm /
toast that's $20 off your first kid at
modern fertility calm / toast so excited
to be working with this brand I think
it's very like toasty and so I feel like
something that we need to get ahead of
as win and they also feel like people
like don't are like almost like
embarrassed to talk about it but it's
like this is something we should be
talking about openly because I feel like
the more every time I made the toaster I
met a toaster this weekend who was
having a lot of trouble getting pregnant
she was in the toasters getting pregnant
group and then she finally got pregnant
and she said like talking about it with
other people who go through the same
thing is what makes it so much easier
and like less like stigmatize you know
right like you makes you feel less alone
1 & 9
there's not something it's not you alone
I'm the only person who's dealing with
it so modern for Chile calm Santos
everyone's up
okay next story super interests on day a
little movie news makeup maidens to get
The Devil Wears Prada movie treatment
oscar-winning producer when the fine
ermine known for turning such books as
far as scum from The Devil Wears Prada
into blockbuster movies has optioned
rogue or I think it's Rouge
I don't know buy admitted ends who sang
at the Italian or the American camper
the Italian camper would say Rouge
American camper would say rogue Rome
baby there's a route or route I think
route I think it depends route sounds
like are OoT and like I want someone to
know it's the route ya know it's like
what route did you take or like I mean
route yeah I think I say no is it rude
and I don't know it depends I'm talking
to and if it any time in moira mode
totally oh but if I'm in more about it's
the route an author Richard Kirshenbaum
novel due June 23rd from C Martin's
Press fictional Isis the real-life
female rivals who built the modern
beauty business in the 20th century by
innovating new products at lightning
speed so it's that to their characters
are based on Helena Rubinstein and
Elizabeth Arden and a-list actresses are
ordered yes so it's like a Devil Wears
Prada type movie about two big makeup
moguls I guess they didn't involve Lily
st. Clair right I mean she'll be
devastated but okay I watched Amy
Schumer stand-up special don't give too
much away because I'm dying to watch it
so it only watch the first half and I
have to say Jackie it's hysterical and I
was laughing so loud
Ben was dying it was like very woman
heavy like period jokes and stuff like
just one little thing I had to tell you
it was like it was a little vulgar but
like she was like why are we so
embarrassed if our tampons like we
should just be whipping him out like
everyone so she's like pulls out her
tampon they she's like pretending what
she's gonna do with the tampons and
she's like and then she goes you are
getting sleepy it was really funny I
really enjoyed it
I also just like liked watching and
stand-up like for like notes she doesn't
move around the stage a lot maybe just
because she's pregnant but like everyone
always giving me notes that you should
move around the stage more like what if
she were to do it the Chicago Theatre
stunning then I think I've seen I think
when I saw her at this
port that's the set that she did she
cause like she was talking about tampons
and she talked about tampons on SNL and
her SNL monologue was very similar to
the stand-up that she did oh it was
probably like testing the material yeah
but it was but then I felt like I had
really seen the show no even now I feel
like I saw it it was so funny and oh I
wonder if it's the same thing she did in
the Seaport I think it is because it's
like she was on tour right less than a
year ago okay well the first I would
watch like the first 30 minutes because
I thought of like the idea to watch it
so late that I just wanted to like be
able to talk about her then toast and I
was ready to hate it but it was so funny
and I was just like loving it and she
lifts up her dress and shows everyone
her bump cuz she had to put two
band-aids over her bellybutton because
it was showing through it was like very
pregnant heavy and I didn't code say one
more thing I was sure she was like you
know it was not fun to be pregnant at
the same time as Meghan Markel she's
talking about it's like Meghan markle's
like one day pregnant they're like cuz
they had a bump she's like I was like
six months pregnant for anyone started
guessing it was really funny that is
okay with CL laughing um yes he was a
hysterical like in stitches I would say
oh I'm not jinxing anything okay next
story is unbelievably Shady
Jameela Jamil criticizes Khloe
Kardashian for promoting weight loss
shakes quote be smarter than this okay
Khloe posted an Instagram a fit a flat
tummy co-partnership and Jameela Jamil
commented it quote if you're too
irresponsible to one own up to the fact
that you have a personal trainer
nutritionists probable chef and a
surgeon to achieve your aesthetic rather
than this laxative product and to tell
them the side effects of this non
fda-approved product that most doctors
are saying aren't healthy side effects
such as possible flat tummy T side
effects are cramping stomach pains
diarrhea and dehydration
then I guess I have to it's incredibly
awful that this industry bullied you
until you became this fixated on your
appearance that's the media's fault but
now please don't put that back into the
world and hurt other girls the way you
have been hurt you're a smart woman be
smarter than this okay
I love Jameela Jamil I actually D I'm
trying to Instagram the other day
because she follows me and like if she
responded and I really felt like a
celebrity like responded to me
I never realized like it actually is
like borderline like remember when the
Apotex place in lollipops like
everyone's like Freetown they never did
again like these T's are like definitely
not healthy they're no different than
Anne
then Molly probably think they were
actually made by the same company but
there's like allowances for the tea
there are especially I think what people
didn't like about the appetite
suppressant pop it's like doesn't even
matter what it actually does for you we
shouldn't be promoting appetite
suppressants but like I and I think then
like I didn't fully agree with that like
some people do like need to go on a diet
for whatever reasons and their app it's
helpful if you don't have a big appetite
right so like I don't think that's
automatically a bad thing but yeah I've
never used one of these five times and I
would never work with them because I
wouldn't use them so my money so I
wouldn't write oh my god one time one of
them reached out to me and like what
they want like I don't know how people I
mean the Kardashians are different like
all these Bachelor people who work with
these brands it's like we have they have
some of them have a little bit more
followers than me and it's like what
they were offering me was like you need
to post six times um that's a test we'll
give you a free team you post six times
is test screenshots every 24 hours and
then we could talk about a larger
partnership right like no I mean the
only thing I don't agree with in her
statement and I love Jameela Jamil it's
like the media bullies you into caring
so much about what you look like and I
feel like there's a stigma around like
caring about your appearance like here
somehow vain if you like want to look
pretty or lose weight or put on makeup
or whatever like there that I don't
agree with but the idea that you can't
be beautiful and you only can be
beautiful if you're skinny like that's
what I disagree with and like the fact
that everyone needs to look a certain
way that I disagree with too but caring
about the way you look isn't a bad thing
and I don't think that it should be
stigmatized it's like being shallow or
vain cuz like I'm not shallow
no I agree but I just it's it's not
something well with me because it's like
this whole flat tummy t-strap is like
I'm sure there were 100 Instagram posts
went off yesterday from influencers
Schilling for this stuff so it's like
now Chloe's gonna like bear the brunt of
it when this isn't her fault like she's
just casually provided festival yeah but
don't you think there is a little bit of
it like if someone came to you I was
like we will give you a thousand I'll
give you $100,000 promote this heroine
would you do it ooh
no not right so what you do as a person
with influence especially that
Kardashians are aware of how influential
they are like they have a little bit of
responsibility to really promote like
good not even good products like just
not bad products but I mean no one talks
about the side effects applied to me see
but I thought that was I mean I knew
that it causes like diarrhea and
I didn't know that oh I don't know how I
knew that but I just like I didn't know
that and I didn't know until Jameela
Jamil told me I think Jameela Jamil
needs to take on the fight a meaty
industry like the head hot bet the
marketing person of flats right but if
she takes on Khloe Kardashian like
that's like a huge part of their
business and that's a way of getting to
flat to me she she can't get to him they
bought on Instagram she used to comment
and reply to everyone's comments Oh
interesting
I think there need to be like a bigger
documentary about flat tummy - yes oh my
god tea next it's like now it's becoming
trendy to like make documentaries about
like big scams and frauds next flat
tummy tea seriously or just like where
does the money come nowhere is like the
truth campaign that they're using all
their money or the mt v-- commercials
against jewel like allocate like 1% for
like some of these flat tummy tea brands
that's a great idea
right and have Jamila Jameel like be the
commercials it's like Jewel doesn't even
advertise really
so having counter actually I saw a
commercial for jewel you did yesterday
for the first time well I read this Fast
Company article about them in their
business and it's like they started as
they started advertising eventually they
will be able to like kind of like
cigarettes but it's like the anti jewel
advertising isn't I mean I see it all
the time and I don't see any jewel
advertisements so it's not it's making
jewels more popular but I think that
though they should they there are some
really other bad products out there like
these things that advertise so much yeah
you know really is problematic because
it's getting people who wouldn't ever
smoke hooked on jewel but it's also a
solution because it's getting like
lifelong smokers off of smoking a pack a
day and to just Julian in their office
which is not good but it's much better
now it's better because it doesn't have
to get back but it has nicotine right
and then also its side you don't know
the long lasting of like now we know the
lasting effects of cigarettes because
people I've been smoking them for so
long but we don't know what this yet
some jewel will be no but it's
definitely step in the right direction I
think it is but not when it comes to
like teens and no and new smokers right
so and I feel like even like people in
the clubs like that's where Jules really
go down it's like those people who are
now jeweling in the clubs like also used
to like me the type to be like only
smoke cigarettes when I'm drunk social
social you know and so like they're not
doing that anymore and
they're drooling in the club right so
it's better I think it's better but like
people really do take umbrage with it
and I personally don't but I respect
that you do you know yeah anyways this
and final story the report came out of
the happiest countries in the world and
the unhappy in America is what lasts
number 19 these are the sober no but
here are the ten happiest countries in
the world one Finland to Denmark I mean
make sense that Finland's the happiest
country in the world what do they have
to worry about the recent fiscal crisis
so true to Denmark three Norway for
Iceland men like you are the reason I
left Finland
five Netherlands six Switzerland seven
Sweden eight New Zealand nine Canada ten
Austria and these are the ten least
happy countries with one being the least
happy okay so the least happy country in
the world is the South Sudan so sad
second least happy Central African
Republic third Afghanistan for Tanzania
five Rwanda six Yemen seven Malawi
eight Syria nine bucks Juana 10 Haiti
Yemen very sad wild I mean everything
measure this like this is also just like
a [ __ ] research study you know
anything that someone had to do for
their like tenth grade social studies
project the world happiness report rings
156 ranks countries based on a
three-year average of surveys taken by
Gallup doctors survey participants are
asked to consider include might we speak
reading English I don't know those out
there is survey participants are asked
to consider include their countries GDP
social support from friends and family
healthy life expectancy freedom to make
life choices generosity perceived
corruption and recent emotions reports
Bloomberg if Bloomberg was reporting in
its writing another factor in the
rankings is the effect technology is
having on people's happiness it found
that teens who spent more time with
digital devices we're less happy this
seems to be a trend you know honestly
it's probably just like the happiest
countries have people who just walk
around without bras and all the women
are just happy and nice to everyone cuz
I'm not wearing bras true or they're
wearing third love bras so it's like
they're not wearing a bra so many of
these countries that are the happiest I
feel like are in the same regions like
Switzerland Netherlands Iceland Finland
Denmark Norway I feel like they're all
neighbors yeah so there's something but
they all have a third love discount code
where they all have a third love
discount code
maybe it's the toast I'm gonna throw the
breath today yeah it doesn't feel like
it though actually I didn't sleep with a
bra last night it felt so good feel like
my postures definitely been getting
better ever since I started wearing
third love bras you see it like such
deep marks like in my shoulders from the
straps but now I feel like lighter than
air like maybe it drive be cup I feel
like I do goals well third love is the
best bra company you take a fit finder
quiz online they ask you a bunch of
questions like about your cup size or
spillage you have side boob you have
overhanging boob are your straps to
tighten straps you loose and they find
the perfect bra for you they send it to
you third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they're
offering our listeners our listeners 15%
off your first order go to 3rd love.com
slash morning toast to find your perfect
fitting bra today get 15% off your first
purchase 3rd love.com slash morning
toast for that 15% off today exciting to
day
it's 11:11 make a wish just for the boys
just for the boys wish america would be
the happiest country wish America would
be the happiest country but don't we
have to be happy about we're incredibly
ungrateful or it's like you think you're
happy you know
so you think York happy in America
imagine how happy to be in Finland yeah
I mean I don't know but if you Rebecca
Bloomwood said then the reason men like
them are the reason that she left
Finland I believe it's happy considering
the men right considering that the huge
PR monster storm it took from that film
I wanted to ask you did TPG ever watch
confessions oh no and I told him again
when I was here to watch it cuz I told
him he was the girl in the green scarf
he really is should we in abruzzo we
should but um no I was just gonna finish
reading the article that the biggest
bummer about these findings is that when
you factor in population growth world
happiness has fallen in recent years and
report's authors found the world is a
rapidly changing place how communities
interact with each other whether in
schools workplaces neighborhoods aren't
social media has profound effects on
world happiness I agree so I didn't make
a guest card for today's show because
actually I didn't really know if our
superstar would make it but Theo's here
and he smells so good he got a bath by
Ali he looks so good
he's just I feel like he like he too had
a really good week you know when he too
is feeling like emotionally supported
well rested really productive he's a
couple he was on the phone with his
attorney yesterday like six or seven
business deals on the line so he's
feeling really excited and I'm really
blessed he's looking really good and now
it's become clear you know he obviously
had his Winterbottom slike now he
for the summer yep what are some of his
diet tips that he can share with us does
he use flat tummy t he does not and he
actually is a Jameela Jamil fan and he
really agrees with everything she has to
say
he's very much of the you know diet and
exercise lifestyle it really does work
and Theo's proof he has cut down on his
treats and he has taken extra walks in
the park with his boyfriend Murphy who
loves to take him for walks and he hangs
out with his mom which increases his
happiness and he's just really feeling
mind body and soul peaceful nice and
that's that's good well switching gears
a little bit because this is a show
about pop culture and me Theo is a pop
culture expert considering how much TV
he watches with his mom in room did he
watch Real Housewives of New York last
night he did and what does he think he's
a little bored I'm not gonna lie and he
knows that it's only episode two so he's
really trying to be patient but with the
New York housewives it's like let's go
yeah and Theo was just feeling really
like you know Restless
so who does who is he I got to find what
this season and who is he not here for
okay
he actually is really liking Barbara and
he's super surprised that she can end up
becoming a full-time housewife because
so far she's really in the thick of all
the driving no she doesn't have an apple
oh I am a tag line no but it's like I
think they started filming with the
attention to minute of making her one
but it seems like they didn't like what
she brought so for I'm enjoying it I'm
enjoying it too she's bringing a lot of
rationale to the table and if you need a
tagline it's barb the Builder can she
fix it Lord the Builder yes she can
yes she can yes she's yeah she yes she
can if he is really distracted who is
theö taking umbrage with this season I
mean he's always been like a longtime
critic of Dorinda cuz he really feels
like she gets away with a lot and a lot
of her behaviors kind of and it's
concerning yeah um so he really cares
for and just wants the best for her and
I do think that she cheats who needs to
seek seek help yes she's under a lot of
emotional stress it seems like she can't
even have a conversation next week with
Barbara right and I don't know if LuAnn
said this when she was on the I think
she said it on the show I don't she said
it before because they were talking
about Dorinda's drinking yes and
personal she said she wasn't drinking
and then she was the one who was like
let's open some wine so like there's
clearly something we are
the drink she she appears to have fallen
off the wagon Theo says it's not me and
I think LuAnn had said that cheap
readings for a lot of these um filming
scenes so it's like she's not drinking
there but she is drank right you know
and the thing about drink is like you
can always tell when she's strong cuz
it's like it's all over her for she
she's not subtle
you know I think her lipstick starts you
know know her poets like da says her
words start to slow sounds different so
it's like you know what it's just when
we have a drunker and run our hands ya
know she's she couldn't like I feel like
for a long time Kim Richards was like
very good about hiding her alcoholism
like I didn't really know you know what
was going on with her right and during
is a total opposite yes like it's not
ever a question right says Theo
what did Theo think of what Ramona said
about Dennis last night he thought it
was one of the most horrible vile evil
things he's ever heard anyone says but
were you shocked no no he says he wasn't
shocked about it cuz like Ramona is
known for saying horrible things but
like that one in particular it's okay
they just got home in the clambake where
Bethany has tears in her eyes
how could you right did Co see Ramona's
statement that she put on Instagram I'm
like what did she say there she must be
getting a lot of [ __ ] no I think that
honestly I think she's had a pain about
that statement since she said it and she
knew it was gonna be terrible and
they've been playing he had like a quote
card ready to go which was like I'm so
what Tyler Perry quote no no it was I'm
so sorry for what I said I have only
respect for Dennis and like I've
apologized to his family in to Bethany
she like she is I'm sorry just forgive I
don't know what like it's a terrible
thing to say and like it's indicative of
someone who doesn't want the best for
you and if there's ever a question why
Beth Ramona is like Bethany like you
don't want to you're not close to me
like you don't open up to me if there's
ever a question Ramona your answer is
right there right cuz you think things
like that who can even think that let
alone say it right
evil what did CEO thinks of Bethany's
engagement ring the biggest thing I've
ever seen in my life
Theo really thought he'd never seen
anything so big in his whole life and he
was shook that there wasn't more
pictures of it like on the Daily Mail
and stuff like like I need I need more a
close-up like I need to know what's
going on it's so pretty is it oval or is
it it's oval I think it's funny has a
heel it's like a massive version of mine
it's huge it's gorgeous I hope she never
takes it off totally it's a cocktail
ring though yeah she's seeing someone
good for her yeah really just deserves
happiness and I know and she's our kind
of hard time finding it it's she's oh
yeah but you know what that's her cross
to bear
it is her cross to bear you gotta have
it like you really can't have it all not
even cuz like women can't have it all
cuz women can do whatever they said
their mind being God only gives you so
many blessings no one has you know every
single box ticked off in line with no
negative right everyone has it's a it's
a scale I took of cards it's a scale um
how's the old feel about tensley in
general he's just waiting for her to
cross over to the good side it's like
when she went Ramona said that I think
Tinsley was like mortified to be
associated with the blondes like that's
Tinsley's better than that and so is
Sonja yeah and but Sonja is pretty much
the only one in the middle like Tinsley
is very much rooted herself in the
blonde team side and I think she's
better than that yeah I think team
blonde is breaking up Dorinda and Ramona
I like are perfect for each other like
go frolic but Sonja and Tinsley are very
much like in the middle they're classy
broads and I think they they might need
to be moving over to the dark side
literally understood well thank you so
much Theo I started trying to do in my
house I seen it I saw ID portraits and
digital photos and now I'm gonna start
to get his like pictures have imprinted
I'm like I'm gonna go to canvass people
or get like little bags and hats and
shirts with your name on it and your
picture on it like so cute yeah that's
what I'm gonna do actually it's what I'm
gonna use my code for for canvases yeah
okay yeah but like I'm gonna get him on
Gina style yes oh my god when he said
your dog it's beautiful you know it's
not um like selfish if it's not of you
know totally and he was a work of art
and loved Theo
kimba's people can print your favorite
photos on canvas for really unique
prints so I have three pictures on my
wall already but I think I need like top
to bottom like a bunch more canvases
like someone's of him been and I wanted
to do a naked photo shoot of me him and
Theo and then we can have canvas people
printed for I'm naked
why does have to be naked like a nude
photo shoot like a glamorous nude photo
your breasts psyche or it's just like
look how my the overhead cover my nipple
that no why yes that is like that's
creepy whatever canvas people prints
your favorite photos on canvas for
really unique beautiful prints great for
decor like me they're really like pieces
of art and
is already a piece of art so we have an
offer for you guys as a special and
special limited time offer canvas people
is offering their popular 11 by 14 photo
canvases for free that's right for free
these normally sell for $69.99 but for
this week only you'll pay nothing just
cover shipping and handling to get your
free canvas text toast to 79 79 79 just
pay shipping and handling and the offer
won't last so text TOA st - seven nine
seven nine seven nine that's toast - 79
79 79 message and data rates you know
what they may apply and nurse and much
like Theo is applying himself to being
such a good boy right now he's so cute
I'm so glad that he came today for our
last show of too many questions for Theo
I mean I always have questions for him
how does he feel about the way he's
being represented on Instagram these
days like I know he has like a new news
new management management and what is
what are his thoughts I know you love me
too and that's what's gonna keep us
together for so long it's the strength
we had for each other meeting bed-leg
lay in bed and like literally like
attack Theo and then we look at each
other like what are we gonna do with me
of a child like I can't imagine loving
anything more more holy and purely than
I love sealed like I would really jump
in front of a bus for Theo and then it's
like when you get a dog that you mean
when you have a child like you're gonna
care about your dog anymore no I can't
imagine me loving your child more than I
love Theo like I don't know how that's
possible like I think about Theo
all of the time I have a photo of Theo
in my house I don't think I'm having a
photo of your baby in my house what
that's so mean when I would like the why
would I
soon nephew I don't nice I and I mean
maybe maybe there's just something about
me that's like very like I have the aunt
chromosome you know because I guess most
people don't have a picture of their
sister strong in their house like again
this but you you have an aunt in your
blood
idea he's blunt I just like I don't want
the show to end I know stop telling
everyone how much I love Thea and
because like we're not here tomorrow oh
oh
but speaking of my amazing hosting
skills and interviewing most precious
gem alive Claudia and I did a patreon
episode where I interviewed her
as the comedian that she is like not as
like my sister toast co-host like as an
up-and-coming comedian I got to speak to
real talent and some say voice of our
generation so that will be up later
today on patreon.com special morning tow
so you can listen to it tomorrow though
we will not be here then next week I'm
holding down the fort on my own I have
some exciting codes for switching things
that you like cozying like what are your
thoughts on colors I mean it always um
like when we're doing it just you and I
together and we don't have any guests
like I have nope it's I show up I'm like
ready to go right whenever we either
have a guest or I'm co-hosting with
someone it's like I wake up that morning
and I'm like Pitts like you know cuz you
never know how it's gonna go unless it's
like a regular but even still it's like
getting them to the studio getting them
comfortable like letting that a lot of
people want to know the stories that
were going to talk about before so just
like giving everyone the run of show and
not until it's over do I relax you know
yeah because I just especially you can
still hear was just like slouch and like
feel okay yeah but on the new coats I
don't know how it's gonna go oh my god
that scared the [ __ ] out of me it's our
fire oh my god feels all an alert
well good thing the show's over over
that's scary burnt toast so Jay you know
I suppose you feel better this happens
at CNN and stuff does it yeah I think
you can't help should we wrap up like is
there fire oh well Jake is checking so
in the meantime um well if they are
denied my heart do it so great okay oh
my god my chest hurts I was so scared
yeah I get scared so easily do you um
not as easily as you who I didn't smell
anything
Teredo no unclear okay well we'll wrap
it up anyway all right we're done the
deals on high alert so cute I will see
you on Monday with Jared freed so I'm
really excited to get to know him pick
his brain and have a little bit of a
different perspective on this show a
man's perspective a straight man's
perspective right all right well if you
can hear this bye everyone have a good
day see you on Monday
[Music]